un cambio de tono en las negociaciones
después de tres reuniones en belarús y
algunas citas por teleconferencia los
equipos de ucrania y rusia se reunieron
por primera vez en estambul y así
resumió la jornada del gobierno turco
hoy se ha logrado el avance más
significativo desde el inicio de las
negociaciones
ucrania propuso a rusia su voluntad de
ser neutral y de renunciar a entrar en
la otan a cambio pide garantías de
seguridad en su territorio entre los
países sugeridos para defenderles israel
canadá polonia y turquía
hoy le estamos entregando nuestra
propuesta a la parte rusa nosotros
decimos esta es nuestra posición dejamos
nuestra posición oficial y luego
esperaremos respuesta en cualquier
acuerdo necesitaría ser aprobado por
referéndum y ucrania y mientras la
delegación rusa estudia las propuestas
dejó un gesto de buena voluntad
teniendo en cuenta los principios
discutidos hoy el ministerio de defensa
de la federación rusa decidió de forma
momentánea reducir la actividad militar
en dirección a kiev y ser ni hits para
aumentar la confianza mutua y
condiciones necesarias para futuras
negociaciones
sin embargo la cuestión territorial
todavía está lejos de resolverse
ucrania sugiere un periodo de 15 años
para negociar sobre crimea mientras
rusia ha estado buscando que kiev acepte
la anexión de la península desde 2014
también ha pedido que reconozca como
independientes los estados de donges y
lugar en el donbass además antes de la
invasión el presidente vladimir putin
había reclamado todo el dow más incluida
la ciudad de mariupol hoy en ruinas por
los combates cuestión que podría ser
tratada por las partes muchos creemos
que hemos trabajado con suficiente
material para que sea posible una
reunión entre los presidentes de ucrania
y la federación rusa y para ello rusia
dice que antes tiene que haber un
acuerdo de paz